here we are the head's made of cheese
said more to Santas please
yes Ron is on a roll according to this
new Wisconsin poll
a straw poll now made with real straw
I don't even know why I left that in
there
that's Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
ahead of Donald Trump as the preferred
GOP front-runner in 2024 and we'll know
the moment the media takes to Santa
seriously when they label him a white
supremacist
conducted over the weekend at the
Wisconsin Republican convention or work
attendees were asked to choose between
dozens of potential candidates for
president as well as a variety of
homegrown cheeses
30 38 percent of Voters chose DeSantis
compared to 32 percent for Trump and the
remaining 30 percent move to Florida
this is just one of many recent polls
echoing a broader sentiment that
governed DeSantis popularity is growing
faster than Douglas Murray's biceps
I did I not tell you the orphan blood
would work
[Laughter]
so if Trump decides to run again he
might have his work cut out for him in
the Republican primary but before we
draw any conclusions the poll comprised
of only what 325 people that's smaller
than other straw polls but larger than
the audience for The Daily Show
yeah this is interesting because
well I'm not going to tell you what I
think I want to know what you think
about this I think Ron DeSantis has been
an extraordinary excellent superb
governor of Florida and he's made
national news on any number of fronts
and I was there in 2018 when President
Trump was campaigning for Ron DeSantis
helped him in the primary helped in the
general we almost had Andrew Gillum yes
look him up governor of Florida and I
look I think that results produce
consequences and that's why there's a
buzz around Governor DeSantis he'll have
a monster reelection he's raised I think
100 million dollars but on this
particular straw poll I think people
like to make a big deal out of Trump's
endorsements this draw about that show
325 people is less than I had at my
wedding and I think that I wasn't
invited
oh wait better luck next time and um
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Applause]
yeah Sting and yeah but
um how did roguefort do in the poll by
the way you didn't tell us who roguefort
who's that cheese
I think that look I think Trump running
he wants to he'd love to run in 2024 for
two big reasons what number one he
there's so much unfinished business he
wanted to tackle in the second term and
number two relatedly Joe Biden is
running this country on Spite and spite
is no way to run a country everything's
unraveling because Trump did it he wants
to undo it and he sees like we all do
that people are hurting you have infants
that can't get baby formula have people
dying of drug overdoses the border is
insecure Putin's in Ukraine Iran's
staring at Israel it all went to I just
wish these infants would stop crying
but I don't know what a bunch of
snowflakes does I don't know if DeSantis
guns if Trump does
and I know the donors are very hot onto
Santas and they're always wrong if I
were Rhonda Sanders I tell the donors
please stop saying my name they usually
pick the wrong person all right so
Douglas I'm gonna float you my theory do
you know there was this research about
uh there were a lot of Airline disasters
in South Korea and it was because like
they the the assistant Captain co-pilot
wouldn't tell the head pilot when he was
making a mistake so they switched him
right they made the co-pilot the pilot
so the person with more seniority was
the co-pilot who would tell the other
guy what to do my theory is should
wouldn't it be great if the Santos run
with Trump as VP
mind-blowing right I know I know that's
worse than your theory earlier about
self-driving cars I don't understand
your theories but I'm saying that like
uh you have the guy who's been there
saying okay this is what you should do
it's like it's like he has his Protege
as president yeah there's one problem
with that uh Trump's the leader of the
America first movement and he's we don't
think of him as a number two Trump would
like to be vice president you really
think that no I just thought
you really see a situation where he said
I'd like to replace Kamala Harris
how much fun would Trump as VP be oh
sure
hilarious he would do whatever he wants
to be hilarious he'd just be great yeah
this is great this reminds me of sports
let's trade LeBron James or two role
players in 50 bucks it is true this is
not happening this is my fanny Fanny
fantasy politics league so you you think
it's a stupid idea no I just didn't
follow the logic okay
don't expect Logic for me it's because
you don't speak Gutfeld I speak Gutfeld
what then it didn't address what I just
said translate tell me what I meant to
say uh no you said what you meant to say
it's just wrong
um are these are bad reviews from your
panelists
very bad reviews the stock doesn't need
to be the VP to do whatever he wants he
was the president who did whatever he
wanted I just find this whole poll
though just a big old tease we got two
and a half years left of Joe Biden this
is like getting everybody's hopes up
yeah it is true we're not even halfway
through this mess right we gotta claw
our way through this
yeah cause you is struck a nerve there
will
either that or the cafeteria food we fed
them finally hit them
you redeemed your terrible Trump is Vice
President I Do by giving them a worse
thing to focus on
I was just thinking it was like I was
trying to make this interesting guys
president Trump is the leader of the
America first movement the America first
movement is taking over state by state
across this country and isn't it
fascinating that we're sitting here
debating two really strong politicians
on the right and you can't find one and
that's not partisanship that is a fact
you can't find one on the left here at
here my next Theory
America's second
because like being in the second spot
you could help the other country like I
don't know I love you like this keep
going yes yes yes so Canada First
America second winner thank you all
right brilliant I think I salvaged that
segment